June first means it is the first
official day of hurricane season the
national oceanic and atmospheric
administration NOAA predicts there will
be fewer storms than normal this year it
forecast calls for zero to two major
hurricanes plumbers David gira has the
details all right so Noah is saying
here's a reason for that prediction is
that they're gonna be warm temperatures
in the Pacific this is known as El Nino
of course when they forecast for below
normal season that can often be
inaccurate a forecast is just a forecast
and perhaps the most salient example of
that comes from 1992 that was supposed
to be a below normal year that was when
Hurricane Andrew a category 5 storm hit
the US and caused a tremendous amount of
damage more than 25 billion dollars
worth of insured losses that was the
fourth costliest disaster in the last
40-plus years now more more investors
are paying attention to hurricane season
they've been pouring money into what are
called catastrophe bonds or cat bonds
these are high yield instruments
alternatives to traditional reinsurance
and the way they work is if there were
no major hurricanes the investor is
going to get a pretty good return
especially in this year low-yield
environment but if there are
catastrophic terms he is storms he plant
he could lose tons of money and
investors like these because the returns
that they can get and because they're
not correlated the stock market they're
correlated to weather now since the
financial crisis the bond market has
seen double-digit annual growth in these
22 point 1 billion dollars worth of cat
bonds were outstanding at the end of
March and so these are being issued by
reinsurers and insurers they're
increasingly popular with hedge funds
and with pension funds now not everyone
thinks that they're surging popularity
is a good thing and what's cracking a
lot of pretension is this new book out
by three business school professors
they're arguing that these are in fact
very risky and as that risk is being
spread around maybe investors don't
fully appreciate how risky in fact they
are so staff and Eric just to recap the
way these work if I'm a small business
owners say in the Carolina coast I take
out insurance because of because of the
hurricane the insurer goes to the
reinsure to allay some of that risk
further now that is being parceled out
farmed out even further to investors
that's the way that these cat bonds are
working yikes that doesn't sound like
2006-2007 thank you it gave it girl